[Musique]
aujourd'hui on cuisine vapeur parce que
c'est bon c'est facile et surtout ses
santé
on connaît la marguerite on utilise
parfois les tuent veuze mais rarement
les paniers de bangui ça nous permet une
petite versatilité un petit peu plus
grande on va pouvoir venir déposer les
bouchers déposer les morceaux de poisson
ou de viande puis faire des cuisson
vapeur mais c'est le même principe au
final c'est vraiment la vapeur il fait
office de chaleur
un des avantages les étages qui
permettent de cuire différents aliments
en même temps le principe c'est déposer
un rond qui convient à la casserole
parce que ce qu'on veut c'est garder le
plus de vapeur possible qui va traverser
notre système de panier si on en a pas
évidemment on pourrait installer ce
système là dans le fond de la casserole
on viendrait déposer nos panier vapeur
et à ce moment là pour garder le maximum
9 heures forêt venir mettre à couvert
par dessus
un panier comme ça doit valoir à peu
près 1 4 dollar vous en achetez un par
personne et à la maison chacun fait son
saumon à la saveur qui veut donc c'est
une activité en elle même on dépose le
pavé de saumon à moi je vais mettre de
l'huile de césar à moi je met du piment
à moi je vais mettre si je vais mettre
ça trois seulement trois saveurs trois
étages on commence par le saumon à la
taille ensuite je mets le saumon au miso
et érable et je termine avec mon citron
et un tout simplement onco voyait déjà
la vapeur et là il reste plus qu'à
attendre
bah faut juste le faire intelligemment
plus il va ailleurs de jus qui risque de
couler plus on va le mettre en dessous
puis on va monter dans les étages les
choses qu'on veut pas mélanger les
saveurs c'est sûr et certain que la
vapeur on sûr puis jamais beaucoup trop
donc si vous l'avez laissé 15 minutes au
lieu de 10 minutes le 5 minutes oui aura
cuit la chair du saumon par exemple mais
il sera encore tendre il sera pas sec ça
pardonne les erreurs
pas besoin de 8000 francs il faut juste
utiliser du papier tout est comme celui
ci ou simplement du papier parchemin
percée sinon feuille de salade feuille
de chou et c'est en moi dans mon cours
de danse ling on utilise des feuilles de
chou chinois qu'on dépose au fond
puisqu'il faut ce que la vapeur puis se
rend donc on veut rien d'hermétique pour
les légumes d'accompagnement on empile
aussi si je sais que mon chou de
bruxelles sera moins vite près que mon
brocoli mais je le mets en dessous comme
ça je vais pouvoir retirer facilement
brocoli et remettent le couvert pour
poursuivre les poursuivre la cuisson
jonathan donne aussi un atelier
culinaire avec les paniers de bambou on
reprend notre pote faites vous de la
place vous allez en avoir besoin parfait
un peu de farine brioche au port
d'hommes plink pékinois ou aux crevettes
tout est cuit à la vapeur c'est quand
même dur et de puissance y est pour le
premier paniqué en contact avec des
casseroles essentiellement oui tant que
la vapeur travers ces traverses de haut
en bas puis on a à peu près la même
quantité donc on n'a pas vraiment de
variation après cinq six étages
peut-être mais sur trois quatre étages
là on est presque bon dans une minute ou
deux vous allez pouvoir goûter à ça
c'est bon vous avez un petit couteau
vous pouvez le coupé fait attention
c'est très chaud la principale légumes
on peut même avec les paniers faire du
dessin j'ai pris la même pâte à brioche
que j'utilise normalement avec du porte
chars sous le bain là j'ai eu garni
cette pâte là avec de la banane et du
chocolat donc ça peut très bien faire
une petite bouchée déjeuner ou une
bouchée pour le goûter quand les enfants
arrivent de l'école on a mis ça sur la
vapeur puis ça fonctionne très bien le
bambou c'est durable mais il faut en
prendre soin essentiellement à la vo
chaude savons éponge ce qu'on veut pas
c'est que ça colle ou sa caramélise mais
la vapeur fait que d'habitude derrière
une colle ou à peu près dans les paniers
donc un bon coup d'eau un peu de savon
puis c'est bon je les passerai par la
machine parce que exposé le bois trop
longtemps à l'eau ça sera pas ça sera
pas une bonne une bonne idée mais ça
sèche bien ça se conserve c'est pas très
cher c'est un accessoire de plus et moi
je l'utilisais autant comme utile de
cuisson que comme outil de présentation
c'est un outil à celle phone et aux
besoins dont on achète des étages
supplémentaires plus la famille
s'agrandit plus on en met
[Musique]
à